[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Paris le général de Gaulle a présidé
la célébration solennelle du centenaire
de la Croix-Rouge dont le nom est
inséparable de celui d'Henri Dunant ce
jeune voie de 31 ans qui avait 4 de ses
concitoyens avaient entrepris voici 100
ans de faire partager au monde l'horreur
que lui avait inspiré sur le champ de
bataille de Solférino les souffrances de
40 000 blessés
[Musique]
dès 1863 leur initiative s'était
traduite par la création du Comité
international de secours aux militaires
blessés l'année suivante 16 pays signé
dans la salle de l'Alabama la Convention
de Genève et le premier ordre de mission
porte la date de mars 1864
la guerre de 70 le siège de Paris vire
la Croix-Rouge multipliée cet âge
humanitaires qui n'ont cessé de
s'étendre dans le monde entier
alors où la Croix-Rouge française vient
de fleurir le tombeau du soldat inconnu
160 millions de volontaires poursuivent
aujourd'hui la tâche d'Henri Dunant
[Musique]
à Paris au ministère des Affaires
étrangères les conversations
franco-guinéennes se sont achevés par
une signature en présence de Monsieur
tridoulet ministre de la Coopération
messieurs se foulaye Diallo Chef de la
délégation guinéenne et Louis Jacques
ministre d'État ont signé une série
d’accords qui après 5 ans de séparation
ouvrent une aire de coopération entre
les deux pays
[Musique]
aucun des honneurs classiques aux
États-Unis n'aura manqué à Cooper à son
retour du cosmos il a parcouru Broadway
sous la pluie de confettis et de
serpentins que l'Amérique réserve à ses
héros comme le signe même du triomphe
c'est d'ailleurs paraît-il la pluie de
papier la plus épaisse qu'on ait vu de
mémoire de New York
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais il est sûr que rien ne aura valu
pour l'astronaute au 22 août la joie de
retrouver sa femme et ses filles à son
arrivée à Hawaii au lendemain de son
retour
un sourire vaut quelquefois toutes les
gloires
Arnaud salacou président du jury du 16e
Festival de Cannes en présence du
ministre de la Formation Monsieur Alain
Peyrefitte a félicité luchinovis quanti
qui recevait des mains de Jeanne Moreau
la palme d'or pour son film Le Guépard
et le prix spécial du jury a été décerné
au film japonais hara-kiri
par ailleurs le prix d'interprétation
féminine est allé à Marina Vlady
récompense applaudit mais aussi discuté
mais le 16e Festival de Cannes n'en aura
pas moins connu son succès habituel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis 62 ans qu'il existe le concours
Lépine ne compte plus ses succès mais on
n'avait pas encore trouvé le
tire-bouchon automatique justement le
voici
[Musique]
cette invention nettement marquée par
l’époque n'a réduit en rien la floraison
des pédaliers améliorés c'est pourquoi
nous sommes allés voir le doyen des
petits inventeurs pierre de Vitry qui a
plusieurs gros succès à son actif
notamment le pipi lumineux
je suis gay en 1892 à Charenton j'ai des
globules Auvergnate et Frank Antoine
j'ai commencé les inventions alors je de
12 ans donc comme vous voyez je suis
l'inventeur des lumineux sur tous les
toits des taxis
plus de 60 inventions sont l’œuvre de ce
chercheur infatigable dont le registre
s'étend du chausse pied à brosse
incorporée aux multiples gadgets
motocyclistes dont les usagers de la
route tiraient bon profit et dont les
brevets sont libres pour le monde entier
[Musique]
en 1950 j'avais fait un Baraton lumineux
mais qui était dur et comme j'avais de
temps en temps à Cannes les agents
là-bas m'ont demandé que je leur passe
inventant mais souffle voyez-vous il est
souple vous avez un bout
pour éclairer les papiers vous avez ici
le stop vous avez le porte au crayon et
vous avez ainsi fait
sous l'Occupation m'avait volé un vélo
réveillez-vous ce que j'avais fabriqué
c'est un bouchon qui est placé sous la
fiche de selle et qui traverse alors le
plus beau c'est de voir le type sautant
sur le vélo en voltige il va pas bien
loin il descend aussi sec
dans ce domaine de la défense et de
l'antivol on le voit pierre de Vitry
ancien chauffeur de taxi et réellement
passé mais
pour faire face à la marée téléphonique
qui a ça l'homme moderne il fallait
aussi trouver quelque chose
[Musique]
3 départements français en état de mort
lente vouée au garrigues aux oliviers
rabougri à une production viticole sans
qualité tel était la région du baron et
du Languedoc voici 5 ans lorsque des
bulldozers commencèrent à creuser un
profond sillon de 25 mètres de large
ainsi pour les corps un projet
d'irrigation né disons le tout bas en
1847 il s'agissait de créer un fleuve
artificiel de 280 km de tarascoing
Narbonne de façon à irriguer 200000
hectares de terre
la technique moderne a fait avancer
rapidement ce nouveau travail d'Hercule
au sud de Beaucaire le Rhône donne
aujourd'hui naissance à une voie d'eau
dont le débit 75 mètres cubes par
seconde et celui de la Seine et qui
constitue la mort d'une des entreprises
hydrauliques les plus importantes du
monde et en même temps des plus
audacieux au bout de 12 km ne fallait-il
pas brusquement élevé de 30 mètres cette
masse d'eau
on édifia dans ce but à pige grue la
plus puissante station de pompage
existantes et un seul homme aujourd'hui
préside à ce défi permanent lancé à la
nature faire couler en quelque sorte un
fleuve à l'envers
[Applaudissements]
grâce à ce tour de force l'eau du Rhône
peut aujourd'hui aller redonner la vie à
une région qui devenait peu à peu un
désert
[Musique]
dès cette année un gigantesque jardin
potager et fruitier de 40 000 hectares
s'étend sur les rives du nouveau canal
[Musique]
là où l'aridité avait fait abandonner
les terres là où elle avait chassé les
hommes et fait mourir les villages est
né l'embryon d'une Californie française
qui dans 10 ans couvrira 200 000
hectares
[Musique]
de nombreux châteaux d'eau recréés
aujourd'hui ce qui manquait à ce pays
brûlé par un ensoleillement quasi
permanent la pluie vivifiante
conséquence de cette renaissance
agricole un premier Marché Gare est né à
Nîmes saint Césaire d'autres suivront
ainsi toute une région jusqu'à
maintenant déshérité est en train de
devenir une des plus riches de France
[Musique]